the attack on Saudi Arabia's largest oil
facility is sure to have a ripple effect
on drivers here in this country Kris Van
Cleave is at a gas station in Washington
DC Chris what can we expect to see at
the gas pump today I see the price
behind you two dollars and 68 cents of
paying cash well good morning Gail the
prices are likely to go up but we won't
see is fuel shortages disruptions to
supply here but you will see signs like
that one ticking up in the coming days
as it will cost Americans more to fill
their tanks now one fuel price expert
tells CBS this morning he expects the
jump will be between 10 and 25 cents per
gallon he calls the increase quote
annoying but not likely to change
consumer behavior now heading into the
weekend the national average for a
gallon of gas had been steadily dropping
with the end of the summer travel season
yesterday the average price was 256 a
gallon down 15 cents from July and how
long the spike in gas prices will last
that depends on how fast the Saudis can
restore production and at this point we
don't really have estimates on how long
those repairs will take we know that
some of the capacity that's offline is
expected to come back sometime this week
but gas price experts tell us the longer
this drags on the longer this disruption
goes on the higher prices are likely to
go Anthony Chris thank you